pre-order bonus oh my gosh
dude the animation on them dropping in
that's not stupefying somebody's right
away
we're starting off strong
oh my God that's so cool yeah so that
you'll you'll notice right away like
when we use Avada Kedavra that guy's how
far went from instant to zero and we
really are trying oh my gosh
yeah it was super important to us that
this space really did feel like
um your reflection uh as a wizard so you
can change the architecture in here
what
this is beautiful we never expected it
to be oh my God
it bins exactly right not only can you
change the architecture here but you can
actually conjure things that we just
didn't even anticipate you can see so
except for the bedside tables there's
like statues that you can do and
ornaments and tables and rugs and just a
bunch of little things we're playing The
Sims is this Animal Crossing
showcase just outside Hogwarts which I
love that we can you can walk out of the
castle after walking through everything
and then just come out here and take off
on your broom out into the open world oh
my goodness Alan I know that's something
that you particularly incendio icon on
the right over there pretty sure that's
incendio I'm a big fan of just being
able to hop on the broom and go anywhere
there's something about kind of like the
the sensation of of everything being
open to you and just oh let's go dude I
can get to things I love flying close to
the ground and and I I kind of wanted to
talk about it just because I feel like
um you know the brooms are fun for me
not just because I heard somebody
talking
but but because they're not just I have
a broom and it's done uh I actually kind
of like some of the mechanics in it so
you can oh my gosh all these little
things popping up there and occasionally
as Andrew's kind of flying up or flying
down you might notice it in draining or
not and and this isn't the present day
where all the room technology is well
known and advanced and and everything
that we know and love this is an earlier
time where they're still trying to
figure out you know we're not at the
3000 yet we're like we're at the 11. so
I just I'm just so speechless right now
because this is just so beautiful sorry
Macy I was trying but it's uh another
language is that like the only one or
can you here we go
so we have a good question Ben
that the player could customize
themselves based on their own Aesthetics
so they're purely cosmetic but purely
cosmetic okay shopkeep and help him out
he'll actually sell upgrades
yeah and those those upgrades will nice
where normally the broom you can only
fly
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo meter down there
you can only go it yeah without the
meter going down kind of closer to the
ground and as you raise into the air
you'll notice the meter drop and so
those upgrades will allow you to
increase that distance from the ground
and there the the broom owner at at the
sporting goods store in in hogsmead is
trying to perfect the broom and get
better oh I love it and know it better
and you can participate that and get
better and better brooms through this I
see and I love that that mechanic
encourages you to actually explore the
world and kind of stay close to the
ground it's not just a travel mechanic
point A to point B you're not just
flying high over everything although it
is beautiful
as well there's lots to lots to explore
on the ground and so kind of keeping you
down at the ground to me it feels like
it's got this kind of Surfing Vibe over
there like I'm just like I want to
snatch the controller from Andrew right
now because I want to go to the
Mountaintop I'm going to the forest
enter that Hamlet
and so uh we all know for more that
hogsmeade is the only all Wizarding
village within Britain oh
slick meet other characters out here and
to kind of populate the landscape so
it's not just kind of you know Barren as
you leave out this direction dude so we
just imagine these different dwellings
these different smaller locations that
that Wizards might live so much to break
down right Scottish highlights right and
so it's a cute little tip and so we
refer to those as hamlets and their
opportunities to learn those wizard
stories
um how those different locations have
kind of like learned to live what their
relationships are with characters that
Hogs me from Hogwarts and so they're
both Quest opportunities out here and a
chance to kind of get to know more of
the area even Beyond Hogwarts and
hogsmead that we've already experienced
and you'll also notice on the mini map
like lots of little icons and each one
of those represents the kid over there
pretending to write a broom I think
participate in you know whether it's a
vendor or different puzzles and
challenges or different secrets that
exist
um each one of those icons are different
opportunities for gameplay and you'll
notice that that same thing as we
venture out into the open world as well
so when you go out into the open world
and you see see those icons whether
they're on the mini map or on your map
or off all the icons so many breakdowns
capacity there are puzzles left behind
by old Wizards you know that you can
solve that actually come on drop the
name drop the name ruins off in the off
in the distance and you visit them
it's Merlin and learn about your ancient
magic and as you and as you kind of
encounter different enemies dotted on
the landscape sometimes those characters
poachers or dark Wizards might be
hoarding different uh magical resources
that are valuable to you have a little
butter beer so each one has kind of like
a way to connect to our gameplay loops
and provide different opportunities that
just kind of reward you for post oh I
didn't see a sitting
but there is something that we haven't
done so far and that is uh oh my gosh
yes
um we're gonna hop on our honestly let's
go dude Sonic's hippogriff is our
pre-order bonus
of course yeah um the animation on that
ground Mount and you can lift off into
the air and we tried to make sure that
each each of those so the broom's really
good at reaching that top speed at that
kind of traveling the world as quickly
as possible but sometimes it's really
nice to get on the hippogriff because of
that ground speed uh or those
transitions interesting and sometimes it
just feels amazing just to be writing oh
yeah always Alan always yeah it's it
really is kind of like uh I don't know
it's a great feeling being on it and
it's a great feeling managing those
transitions kind of going from run to
fly and so you can't just run around on
the ground
that each one of these things that you
can interact with so interesting
identity and a reason for being
and oh my God like I see like different
like two wheel information by the way
can you go to like entire map anywhere
you go there are regions that are like
blocked from you yeah as soon as as soon
as you there's kind of a moment where
the world kind of opens up to your
outside okay Hogwarts as a student and
right from that moment early on in the
game you can go wherever you want no way
my more difficult challenges in
different areas no way responses
Andrew's moving around like you
mentioned swamp
um but there was hoping that was how
it'd be coast and we've got different
types of environments out in the world
just to kind of uh pepper your
experiences which is fresh uh all those
things exist
I love that windmill it's like so rustic
like I keep forgetting that this is like
1800s the wizard in the world would
never really sing before like it feels
so right right like it just it's it's
part of it yeah I love this Vista too
and I can't wait to see this in 4k man
stop here we're gonna use a bit of Dev
magic to uh change the seasons actually
I want to see I want you to see what
this world looks like yes Winter Please
winter yes yes yes ladies for Ben snow
right
[Music]
entering Dev commands
we gotta I mean you gotta show a snow
landscape with our boy Ben snow here
dude look at it
this is so pretty okay and you can kind
of just like hover there in the air with
the uh landscape like completely did you
guys catch that like the hippogriffy
kind of just hover with it for a bit
cool like gameplay impact like impact on
the gameplay or just like it's just the
weather of Scotland uh yeah we use it we
really use it as a narrative marker
through through the game so similar to
it what the movies it's important for us
to kind of like have those moments that
kind of take my money when you're
reading the books or watching the movies
where Gallifrey I'm out title card
winter and now the landscape has changed
and you're really feeling those that
passage of time while you're a student
you know going through it's gorgeous and
this isn't even the 4K version I mean
anybody wanted to duplicate that would
they upload this in 4k oh boy on the
outside which which I I agree I think it
was really beautiful
um but within the school as well so
there are moments like when it reaches
certain holidays or things like that
where hogsmead
holidays oh yeah that's been a big
request decorations around school
reaction holidays that really helped
just kind of make me feel like I'm there
you just confirmed it let's go and it's
not just uh it's not just I mean it had
to be there right it had to be there
those kind of vibe things
um like we have a day night cycle and
that day night cycle even though
similarly like it's largely about Vibe
when you go into Hogs meet in the
evening there's less characters there
around the school who knows it kind of
dies down and quiets down just when
there's just Candlelight and students
kind of like right because some of them
a lot of them go home in that daylight
cycle is where we've kind of placed a
few items where you know whether or not
you can collect them or whether or not
you can interact with them that are a
little bit restricted by the day night
cycle nice and I love Andrews flying up
here really high up on the hippogriff
and and we're just looking at this view
of Hogwarts in the distance it's just
absolutely beautiful dude what I love
most about flying around this is huge
like this is really big you know I I
mean you talk about this is really big
so you can see in the distance and
that's one of my I I still can't it over
like no matter I played like that
question mark right there over the fact
that I can see Hogwarts out there like
what is there not knowing that all
all of the things inside of it the
classrooms the students the professors
all the places I can go I can just fly
my hippogriff land in the courtyard
enter the front doors and just walk you
know to the Walmart gosh dude to my
common room that it's all contiguous get
right one question marks on those
creatures
magical creatures right they look like
wolves or something right now are just
absolutely beautiful interrupt a
charging Mongrel with the pulsive a lot
more time out here see these little
Feats that keep popping up Merlin puzzle
maybe right there sorry this is a great
opportunity to switch over to trying to
like balance how much I'm talking kind
of an intro to combat this time
excitement to go down right now a lot
more of a deep dive so we can hear what
they're saying using the dark arts
battle arena which is part of our combat
deep dive let's go let's go right
Andrew's got us in the Forbidden Forest
which is where the dark arts battle
arena is uh which is part of the deluxe
and digital deluxe edition I I love the
way that the dark arts battle arena is
actually uh part of the world it's
integrated into the world so your
experience is more immersive than just
choosing an option from from the main
menu of the game or something like that
exactly there are many reasons to go to
the Forbidden Forest but uh he's also
wearing the uh dark arts cosmetic set
and uh here he's pulling out the
thestral which is oh my God part of that
dark art pack from the deluxe and
digital deluxe edition so we're going
full full dark whoever had the idea of
doing that
that little pack and the animation
battle arena it is a great brilliant
give that person a raise really combat
in a big way because it unlocks some
interesting abilities for you and allows
you to to really play around with the
little uh little toadstools and is this
like the only Arena like this in the
game where you can like practice it yeah
so in the in the base game we have uh
two combat Arenas normally that and so
everyone has access to those and each of
the combat AR units are an opportunity
to kind of just go through a difficult
combat challenge what wait in order to
earn a a different cosmetic for your
character oh that's cool in the case of
the that's no different than the dark
arts battle arena that's also waves of
enemies the combat Arena but it's uh
unforgivable curse one of the things
that we're excited about confirmed is
the other icon that we've become
pre-loaded with different abilities so
uh the unforgivable curses are something
that everyone's gonna have actually
interesting oh come on Andrew to kind of
blurring out the Spells repertoire and
they can also commit to that balance
that's too funny talents and things like
that when you when you play the Dark
Horse combat Arena you actually have
access to all those things as kind of
like a way to test them all and so it's
a chance to kind of like tour and play
with the dark arts and decide whether or
not that is a path I keep wanting to
pause
um but but yeah everyone has the same
ability to explore explore the dark arts
this is just kind of like a way of
that's cool so for those of us who want
to be purely good no dark arts in
general we can still get a little taste
jump in here still get a little taste of
it you know start battling and we can
start talking about dude the animation
on them dropping in
that's not stupefying somebody's right
away that's eight we're starting off
strong
is that was that cool oh my god oh
that's so cool yeah so that you'll
you'll notice right away like when we
use Avada Kedavra that guys how far went
from instant to zero and we really are
trying oh my gosh on Earth Works in the
game even in some pretty extreme
situations
um you guys like the the meter takes up
a lot longer too yeah build up as a way
to kind of deal with its extreme power
just understandable fun to use and then
there's some some ways that we'll
probably talk about not a finisher
though to adjust that but I don't know
not a finisher's on the screen that you
just have questions about well like I
see like little blue things
from the enemies also we put like that
sign well it's like so in the community
we call it the ancient magic sign I
don't know if that's how it's cold yeah
in the game
it's a magic symbol on the development
side and in player facing in the game we
reference that as your ancient magic
Community
ancient magic meter yeah so as your as
your abilities in the game keep growing
and you become exposed to some of the
secrets about dude there's so much so
much the process here abilities
um you start unlocking new powers so one
of those Powers you'll see the R1 button
appearance right Luna back to back to
back an ancient magic of all three of
them kind of like the draw an object to
you and fling it at an enemy
um okay but whenever you see the R1 or
the L1 plus R1 up here over somebody's
head so that's an ability to count
bottom right guys bottom right notice
the d-pad popping up that's how they're
switching between the Spells there's a
ton of damage against the character and
the way that manifests itself uh we need
to listen to Allen I'll be quiet and
you'll see a wide variety of enemies in
here that are pressuring the player in
different ways you'll notice there's
there's uh abilities that kind of level
up under the player as it's fighting
deaf forcing to move and there's
different ways that we want them there
to kind of move around just torturing
them right there that's actually a good
link to the intermagic reader in general
and the reason I say that is because as
you're doing different things in combat
you're partaging and you're doing
different abilities and you can kind of
speculate your talents there are
different ways to get that meter to
build faster and faster so one of the
most effective base ways to build up
that meter fast that way you can launch
these devastating attacks whenever you
want to is is to actually perform so you
see that contrasting it's almost like
your your emotions are building up and
then basically that built up enough that
you can attack someone but as the combo
meter builds up at some point dude these
Goblin attacks and a piece of their
magic kind of falls out of them you'll
see these blue orbs in in the in the
game world and there's something that
only you can see in in the narrative in
the world and it's another reason to
move around on the battlefield to keep
them go up and collect those things and
suck them in they right Nico the sound
effect on crucio as we're playing
talking a lot about about spells and
Magic here but I think there's another
huge component of combat and that is
that you can bring to combat as well to
kind of uh change the way you play and I
think Mackenzie knows a lot about it
so the the tools are really interesting
because they're basically like a prior
investment so you can bring
you grow in the room of requirement to
combat to essentially kind of help you
um defeat enemies a lot quicker and more
efficiently so some of the tools that
you'll see here are like the rock Skin
Potion so that is something that
basically covers your skin it's been so
much time here material that perfecting
reduces the incoming damage control so
against big enemies hard-hitting enemies
like trolls
um that's super oh two of them
AK in that one all right
obviously we have the wicked little
potion as well
and then we have the focus potion so
when Alan talks about oh my gosh having
to balance a vodacado Dodge long
cooldown obviously it's an instant fill
uh
is through a focus potion and that will
increase
um how quickly your your cooldowns uh
regain right
now like he's just bouncing around
around and then you can then you've
built up AK then you can akm again
oh my goodness I love that our plants
are violent yes and so that's like when
we're talking about the plants almost
the setup of the Arena you also have
plants and so we have things like the
venomous stuff you get an armored troll
down and it acts like a turret and it
just kind of shoots enemies around the
battlefield that is so cool this is like
a truly like hufflepuffian way to
approach the battle
no that was super important to us so
there were things like multiple ways and
so you can see there's there's a ton of
different things you can use uh the
Mandrake is one so you can pull it out
right piercing cries enemies I'm gonna
have to re-watch this so many times
another thing I want to call out uh that
we're seeing on the side of the screen
here is these these dueling Feats which
I love because I love anything that
prompts me to play a game in a different
way a unique way I don't want to get
stuck in my style you know yeah that's a
good question Luna so this is a way to
if it was a one shot for the troll yes
if you just want to blast people with
spells go for it but we also even the
one with full health uh have some things
over here
certain plants or certain potions or
block more or the random objects you
could use
um uh in the prior stream and the field
guide challenge is this is the way that
the field guide manifests like
challenges for you to do
and exactly to your point
um I'm just trying to figure out how
much damage crucio is doing to explore
the different systems he's definitely
stunned over there the guy in the red
over there he's just like explore what
they want to do because there really are
so many different ways there we go we
gotta look at it right there when you
see the the green x's on characters
that's right and that's kind of a
through your talents you can unlock this
kind of cursing mechanic that sort of
like links the fates of these different
characters on the battlefield what uh as
you get them as you're cursing different
characters they all begin sharing damage
and so oh that's things like about a
cadaver which is the insta kill but if
you curse everyone before you insta kill
this one guy they can all drop dead for
that kind of ultimate oh that is sick oh
my god there are there are dark arts
fantasies there's fantasies about being
more of a defense against the dark arts
character things like that that Misty
step that you see um occasionally being
used on the battlefield and we can also
spec into our potions and plants yeah
show us the the defense against the dark
darts Alan it's all about which type of
player you feel like are and whether or
not you want to play with practice oh he
just did oh Imperial like he's just
attacked him and those are all that is
so cool forgot about Imperial like I see
so much like going on on this into so
much complexity and I I want to just try
it myself like which style works best I
mean I feel like it's the Dark Horse
it's gonna be amazing
magic to be honest feels like much more
powerful than just the dark Hearts yeah
and speaking of plants and Potions we
are going to be putting the dark arts
away put those unforgivables they cut
off Allen right there heading to the
room of requirement I wanted to see what
he said about the uh Hogwarts a
personalizable space
utility as well where you get to brew
things and grow things and uh uh also
care for some beasts
right Andrew's got us in the room that
was so good that was so good we kind of
went casual mode on the outfit here
wearing a nice job so here are the icons
in the bottom right that we were
breaking down on the stream last night
trying to figure out what each of those
mean
for uh the personalization of the space
see what you did there Chandler see what
you did character and the visuals of
your character but actually the space is
a place that you can make your own
um yeah it was super important to us
that this space really did feel like
um your reflection uh as a wizard so you
can change the architecture in here
what
beautiful we never expected that to be
oh my God it bends exactly not only can
you change the architecture here but you
can actually conjure things that we just
didn't even anticipate you can see so
except for the bedside tables there's
like statues that you can do and
ornaments and tables and rugs and just a
bunch of little things we're playing The
Sims is this Animal Crossing because
like we we had an idea that those places
where you brew stuff that's what you can
change but you can do a whole of this
where do you even get this stuff like
there's a furniture store
yeah so we call them conjurations uh and
the conjuration recipe conjuration
recipes Frozen Hogs made
um so as you engage in different types
of gameplay throughout the world you'll
be rewarded with uh different objects
that's so cool and you changed color you
can change the color you can change the
size of it and you can place it
basically anywhere
it's like a baby niffler your little
household friends that system two is
designed it's not mechanical what and so
you get the magical effect of conjure
are you kidding me right now you're
actually doing this in the world people
are gonna spend so much time just in
here
I love the animation how it like appears
you know like it's not just like there
it's like it almost like it operates it
is really quite beautiful and that was
the thing is we wanted that looks really
nice because the Magic in The Wizarding
World is everywhere
we really wanted to nail that Whimsy in
this space another thing that I wanted
to discuss is that that animation dude
conjure things and you can change their
their look but you can do that with the
utility objects I have so many thoughts
I'm trying to listen to and potion
stations and you could change the look
of this as well and these are the areas
where as we had mentioned previously
you'll be growing your plants you'll be
brewing your posts I had a feeling I had
a feeling this whole room is required
surprise to a lot of people also the
space where you would bring your gear
Gear to be identified and geared to have
um this is insane dude this is
oh yeah
um we keep bringing up a little hopping
pot over there looks and and on like uh
in the game you can look like anything
you want to whenever you want to
um but the player will be finding
different types of gear that we call it
uh as you progress through the game and
essentially we just know that that
clothes and different items we gotta go
back and read that to digital properties
and as you uh as you explore and as You
Adventure as you defeat enemies you're
going to be finding different pieces of
gear that have different abilities and
that can help you there was blue purple
and growing as a wizard and advancing as
a wizard and so it's a huge list and not
all the time my goodness we never
whenever you get a new piece of gear you
don't necessarily know exactly what it
does and so there's a station inside of
the room of requirement that you can
calling uh called stats
that that gear that you're uncertain
about and learn what its abilities are
right yeah that's so cool and then as
the space advances even further and the
space will eventually grow its own rooms
the rose wolf of death
thank you as well all these different
things keep expanding and as it expands
eventually you're going to earn what we
see here which is called the loom and
when you set up a loom it's an ability
to essentially what's called
extraordinary which magical properties
are on your gear and take any piece of
gear and adjust
what it does and I mentioned earlier
that that you can make anything look
like anything the collection of of cus
uh of
um appearances we call it or um
Cosmetics we've been lost for words
right stream those types of things you
can use and you can apply a look to any
other other look so if you get a piece
of gear you put it on you can transmog
change it to look like whatever you want
nice that's so cool and like you just
you can just put some ability to this
sweater but then you can just swap yeah
that ability yep and appearances you can
edit whenever you want in the gear
screen the loom is specifically about
applying uh traits and and applying uh
larger upgrades that just kind of grant
you greater statistics
abilities blend in nicely with where
you're trying to go with your combat
fantasy increased damage taken from
spiders I'm just like I'm just seeing
that they're just like pump skin fur
mooncuffer where does that come from
yeah and so you'll notice that the
ingredients that are used to add traits
and to upgrade your gear are based
around beasts so this is where we get
into the Beast care section which is
inside oh my gosh here we go on a bigger
space on the inside idea and so you can
see here we have a couple of beasts
calf and a niffler and a knees
up close it's just like a big puppy
oh my God they're together
oh that's so cute they are adorable and
so part of Beast care uh is heading them
as well but feeding them there you go
you do those things
they'll give you their magic clothes
Etc that can then be used in your in
your gear that is like so like intuitive
because like you know that makes sense
because when you touch the animals you
get some fur leftovers that's so
my God yeah and we really want to hammer
home the fact that this is like a home
that you're making for them so in the
Overland you can find these Beast ends
and rescue these beasts part of doing so
is crushing them and feeding them they
cut something she said right there to
build that relationship with with your
beef in addition to be able to care for
beasts you can actually oh I can't wait
to watch 4K as well
yeah right and so we have like a lot of
little diesel right there in this area
and a lot of them are purely cosmetic
but they look really cool again it's the
personalization of this space oh that's
so fun no this is like that's so fun
eight hours just designing this hole do
people are gonna spend so much time just
inside these things like you've got room
of requirements and then within the room
of requirement just for the there's
multiple bavariums I'm pretty sure
there's multiple ones and there's like a
decoration aspect but there's also we
were saying inside uh as well is there's
a utility utility aspect to it too so as
you uh progress in the game and you're
able to purchase more conjurations
you're able to speed up your process so
one of them for example is the food
processor which uh allows dude it's like
a care of magical creatures
within Hogwarts Legacy uh and so you're
really building the progression for
yourself here in addition there's also a
toy box pretty cool where you can play
with your beasts
you'll see here oh my God yeah there's a
bunch of toys
Ellen's a dog trainer you guys
no one is like losing her mind right now
guarantee all right guaranteed
oh my God watching them
there he comes
there you go the world is a dangerous
place and so by going and rescuing these
beasts and bringing them back here and
caring for them you're really helping
helping them out there's poachers in the
Overland uh who want to who hunt these
Beasts for their material so instead
you're caring for them you're giving
them a home eight oh my goodness the
rapcord is just yeah I know he's huge
right but it's way bigger than the ones
we've seen so far
oh you could actually name them as well
these magical materials you can name
them getting back into that
personalization they confirmed it we
didn't want you to just like we were
asking about this last night live stream
you're like oh it can be this or
whatever Andrew's about to name them
let's see Bruce
hello Bruce uh you know we've we've
created this really nice space and and
uh you you can get additional vivariums
correct uh it's a different kind of
Aesthetics there we go I knew it had to
be more than one
yeah your beast and caring for them
percussion is a big part of the space as
well so as you progress through the
story
customizable so as you can see this
one's quite Meadow themed
um big open bright uh but there's other
ones say like a swamp that you might
encounter and it's really a visual
effect to uh and more space for for your
large tree oh so it's like those when
we're inside the room requirement
there's like right right there's that
moon glow from One Tree is well on its
way to becoming a grand old oak
oh you put trees in here too oh my
goodness
and another thing with the the business
losing his mind uh as we are now the
same kind of thing that you did with
like the broom where the broom is not
just a method of travel Pokemon
integrated into the world in the same
way like Beast care isn't just this this
I told you guys like throwing it on top
there's really this like narrative yes
integration too they didn't include a
lot of little mini games but this this
kind of stuff right here makes up for
that I feel like
um as you earn resources you'll go into
hogsmeade and and use them to uh
in the open world uh it's in those
different
um in those different environments like
the different combat and conflicts and
bandicamps and different things like
that that exist in the Overland those
things are what hold recipes uh that
exist in the loom oh my goodness I love
that these things have a way of
connecting
um Moonstone that you find out in the
world is the research how big is this
space like where obviously there are
physical limitations at some point so
really like how how big can you make
this area it keeps you coming back but
even with the story that's being told
too you know I think people know who
poppy is and and uh that she hasn't no
who is she yeah I mean I think
everything we're seeing here you know
you're going to be venturing out into
the world uh and and this is just kind
of the tip of the iceberg even even
though it's kind of like you're
interacting excuse me so you know you're
bringing up you said this is the tip of
the iceberg there are more uh kind of
mysteries to discover and things to
discover around the world that have to
do with her and that have to do with
caring for beasts and so different
characters
I told you that that just kind of make
this all just kind of the beginning the
beginning of your journey
well we could spend hours in here but
yes we could let's stream now let's just
go ahead about what you've seen today
this is I'm just so blown away by how
how beautiful it looks the open world
seems so detailed and there's so many
things to do and like the combat we're
gonna have we're gonna spend like two
weeks or more just breaking it down by
pieces there's just so much
to this world like I'm so happy you guys
know it's been it's like I I don't know
what to say the tip of the iceberg we've
got more for you to discover and find on
your own oh wait oh you know so much for
being here we're gonna be busy for
watching but guys thanks so much for
being here
um I'm gonna go ahead and we'll play a
little music here in the outro but um
thank you all for being here and I'll
talk to you again very soon